it's always nice to wrap up an hour with
something fun and surprising from social
media this is what I'm liking
[Music]
[Applause]
time in our wallets these
these cost more well there's a very
creative woman on Tick Tock making the
most of it by upcycling clothes in the
most creative way just check out some of
our signature Fashions right here
[Music]
that's our real enough that she made out
of bags from retail stores and Tick Tock
is going crazy for it we have Arielle on
the line right now watching on NBC4 Los
Angeles
hello
I mean you're cool I like I can't do
that like what you're doing but how did
you come up with this idea
um so basically July 2020 we were out of
school
um out of here boredom I bought a sewing
machine and then a few days later Fred
and I went to Ikea because he needed
furniture and he jumped around and said
I should make clothes out of the bags we
walked past I was like sure why not so I
bought the bags and I made this outfit I
made it like three days oh my gosh it
would take me three months and it would
look so bad
um so you say this isn't about making a
fashion statement though it's a social
movement as well right yeah
um I think it's really important for
people to try to make anything because
you can literally make anything out of
anything in your house
um and especially the fashion ninja tree
has taught us to buy things and discard
them all the time and I think this is a
fun way to just kind of make clothes for
yourself and just have fun with it
absolutely it's super cool you're very
gifted thank you so much Arielle I'm
liking your post right now
[Applause]
you know pilot pin makers of friction
the go-to race full pen of the Kelly
Clarkson show want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly just like you ma'am
so they're going to give you a thousand
dollars how's that sound
Amer Karen Taylor Grace and The Black
Keys you all have a great day if it's
not try and change it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]